Viserys Targaryen:This world wasn't always
so small and petty.
Thousands of years ago, while the rest of
men prayed to gods, the Valyrians became them.
Through magic or sheer will, they mastered
the greatest creatures in history.
A horse grants man dominion over the land,
a ship over the sea.
But dragons gave us the sky, and everything
and everyone beneath it.
At its height, my ancestors ruled the known
world.
Whatever parts we didn't weren't worth knowing.
Our capital of Valyria shamed the magnificent
cities of the east, for hammers and chisels
were no match for dragonfire and sorcery.
It was a city and an empire built to last
until the end of time.
It didn't.
Four hundred years ago, the Doom fell on Valyria.
Mountains cracked open like eggs.
Lakes and rivers boiled.
Fountains of fire, ash, and smoke spewed from
the ground, so high and so hot that even dragons
burned in flight.
The land splintered, and the angry sea rushed
in.
In hours, the greatest city in history became
history.
But my ancestors didn't burn or drown with
the rest of their race.
Twelve years before the Doom, despite the
sneers of his rivals, Aenar Targaryen abandoned
the capital with his family.
Legends claim that his daughter foresaw the
destruction of the city in a dream.
More likely, Aenar met with some mishap at
court and chose exile over execution.
He and House Targaryen slinked away to a dreary,
remote, godforsaken island.
Forsaken no longer.
With arts now lost to the world, we transformed
a tiny outpost into Dragonstone, a fortress
fit for the last Dragonlords.
Then Aenar's descendants settled into it like
a tomb for their lost homeland.
Until Aegon.
When he looked east, he saw the past: old,
tired, dead.
But when he looked west, he saw the future:
gold in the ground, gold in the fields, and
no dragons in the sky but his.
Varys: Westeros has mighty rivers, but none
of them compare to the Rhoyne.
It is said that there is no stream or puddle
in western Essos but drains to Mother Rhoyne.
No doubt, an exaggeration.Until one sees the
river.
At its widest, a man in the center can't see
a shore to either side.
The greatest of Mother Rhoyne's children were
the Rhoynar, a civilization as ancient and
grand as Old Ghis.
Fishers, traders, scholars, workers of wood,
stone, and metal, the Rhoynar raised their
elegant cities from the headwaters of the
Rhoyne down to her mouth, each lovelier than
the last.
For many centuries, the Rhoynar lived in relative
peace.
When invaders swept down from the hills, the
Rhoynar women and men would don silver-scaled
armor, fish head helms, tall spears, and turtle
shell shields.
If the enemy did not laugh themselves away,
it was said that Mother Rhoyne would whisper
the enemy's secrets to her children, and the
Rhoynish wizards could raise watery walls
to drown their foes.
Whatever magic the Rhoynar may have had, it
wasn't enough.
When Valyrian colonists first arrived, the
Rhoynar embraced them, for all men were welcome
to share the bounty of Mother Rhoyne.
Perhaps a water people should have been more
cautious of strangers who exulted fire and
blood.
Legend has it that one day the Valyrians netted
and butchered one of the giant turtles the
Rhoynar held sacred.
As a result, thousands were killed or enslaved,
cities and towns were burned, drowned, and
rebuilt.
In these wars, the Valyrians emerged as victorious
more often than not.
The princes of the Rhoynish cities, fiercely
proud of their independence, fought alone,
whilst the Valyrian colonies aided one another.
Eventually, the Rhoynish princes ceased their
squabbling and united behind Prince Garin,
who led the largest army Essos had ever seen
against 100,000 Valyrian colonists, 100 war
elephants, and three dragonlords.
Thousands burned, but thousands more sheltered
in the shallows of the river whilst the Rhoynish
wizards raised enormous water spouts against
the foes' dragons.
Rhoynish archers brought down two of the dragons
whilst the third fled wounded, and thereafter
the Rhoynar named Garin "the Great."
But Mother Valyria proved just as caring as
Mother Rhoyne.
When Garin the Great marched his army against
Volantis, three hundred Valyrian dragons descended
from the sky.
Tens of thousands burned whilst others rushed
into the river.
But the fire burned so hot that the waters
boiled and turned to steam.
Garin the Great was captured alive and made
to watch as Valyrians butchered every last
man, so many that their blood turned the great
harbor of Volantis red as far as the eye could
see.
Then they forced Garin to watch as they marched
on his own city and enslaved all the women
and children his army had left behind.
The singers claimed that Prince Garin called
out Mother Rhoyne to curse the Valyrians,
and she, in turn, flooded the city with foul
waters and a damp fog that caused the skin
of the Valyrians to harden and crack, and
thus was born greyscale.
Fearing a similar fate, another Rhoynish ruler,
Princess Nymeria, led her own people into
every ship, skiff, and raft they had and fled
Essos.
Eventually, after much hardship, they landed
in sunswept and bone dry Dorne.
But we all know that tale.
Now Valyria has followed the Rhoynar out of
this world, and her daughters have grown into
Free Cities, wealthy and powerful and proud.
Still, Mother Rhoyne flows on, past ancient
ruins and bustling harbors, sweeping all man's
kingdoms to the sea.
Samwell Tarly:According to legend, House Targaryen
survived the Doom of Valyria thanks to Daenys
the Dreamer, who foresaw the calamity and
convinced her father to flee their homeland.
It could be true.
The Targaryens were always a bit more.
But as Maester Yandel points out, in the East,
the Targaryens were one of a thousand minor
noble families, and in Westeros, they became
kings.
Politics, not prophecy, could have drawn them
to our shores.
Viserys Targaryen: East of Westeros lies the
Smoking Sea, where no ship dares sail.
There are those who swear it to be demon-haunted,
and who's to say they're wrong?
For it was there, thousands of years ago,
that a cataclysmic event occurred, destroying
one of the great civilizations in history.
The precise details of their origins are lost
to us, but it is said the Valyrians were once
a modest community of shepherds, tending their
flocks on a small peninsula of the great eastern
continent.
One fateful day, in a volcanic area known
as the Fourteen Fires, they made a shattering
discovery.
Dragons.
They were monstrous, scaled creatures, with
massive wings, sharp claws, and fiery breath.
They were also said to have a deep-rooted
connection to magic.
In time, the Valyrians were able to tame the
beasts.
Harnessing their immense power, they established
a city of wonder unlike any before or since.
They became skilled at sorcery and metallurgy,
creating uncommon weapons of spell-forged
steel.
Wielding these weapons astride their dragons,
the Valyrians conquered the surrounding lands
and slowly expanded west.
At the time, the Ghiscari Empire dominated
much of the great eastern continent and tried
to stop Valyria's expansion.
The Ghiscari legions attacked the Valyrians
five times, but could never defeat them.
Finally, the Valyrians marched on their capital,
Old Ghis, and obliterated it, turning its
streets and buildings to ash with dragon flame,
and wiping the Ghiscari people and their culture
off the face of the earth.
The Freehold of Valyria, as it came to be
known, became the most advanced civilization
in the known world, with its own language,
gods, and culture.
The Valyrians' reach extended far and wide,
covering most of the continent.
Great cities were built and roadways paved,
all of which led back to Valyria.
The Freehold would prosper for nearly five
thousand years.
But it was not to last.
An event that became known only as the Doom
laid waste to the Valyrians, their capital
city, and its surrounding lands.
The peninsula itself was shattered, becoming
what is now the Smoking Sea.
Every dragon was thought to be lost, as were
the Valyrians' spells, knowledge, and recorded
history.
Thus the mighty empire collapsed.
What caused this cataclysm?
No one knows for certain.
Some say it was a volcanic eruption.
Others say the Valyrians' own sorcery got
the better of them.
In any event, the Doom's devastation of the
Valyrian people was total with the exception
of a small rocky island in the Narrow Sea.
Dragonstone.
For it was there that the Targaryens, the
last of Old Valyria, dwelled.
They would lie in wait for another hundred
years before unleashing the fury of the dragon
on another continent.
Westeros.